jeff works as a waiter at a fancy
restaurant he receives a base amount of
seventy dollars each day plus
approximately ten dollars of tips for
each client he serves or ten dollars in
tips for each client he serves
assuming x represents the number of
clients jeff will serve in a day and y
represents his daily salary draw the
graph which represents jeff's daily
salary as a function of the number of
clients he serves
so he's going to get 70
no matter what so even when x so if even
if he serves absolutely no clients even
if he serves absolutely no one he's
going to get 70 dollars so when x is
equal to zero his pay for that day is
still 70 dollars then he gets dollars
they already told us he gets ten dollars
in tips for each client he serves for
each client he serves so if he goes from
serving zero clients to one client he's
gonna get ten dollars in tips if he goes
from serving one client to two clients
he's gonna get another ten dollars in
tips if he goes from serving two clients
to three clients he's gonna get another
ten dollars in tips and you see that
this line represents all the different
possibilities for him if he goes and
serves six clients he's gonna get sixty
dollars in tips plus the seventy dollars
so the seventy dollars he would have
made otherwise plus sixty dollars in
tips gets them to a hundred thirty
dollars so this right here is the line
and so we can check our answer
we got it right